We've defined moment of inertia
of a rigid body already.
And we often are
interested in it,
because when we rotate
a body about an axis,
say an axis that's passing
through the center of mass.
Then our kinetic energy depends
in that moment of inertia
through that axis.
But we may also want to consider
rotation about another axis.
So suppose we consider
an axis passing
through close to the
end and we rotate
the body around this axis.
You can see from
overhead like that.
Then we want to now consider
how the mass is distributed
about an axis that was
parallel to the axis passing
through the center of mass.
So we'll now make a
little calculation.
But first, we want
to quote the theorem.
So let's just draw an
example of our rigid body.
And let's take the
center of mass,
and let's consider an axis
that's going perpendicular
to the center of mass.
We can think of the object
is rotating about that axis.
And now let's consider
another axis passing
through a different
point, but also parallel
to this axis separated
by a distance d.
Then the result that we want
is at the moment of inertia
about an axis
passing perpendicular
to the plane of the
object through the axis s
is equal to the moment
of inertia about an axis
passing through the
center of mass--
notice these are parallel
axes-- plus the mass
of the object times the distance
between the two parallel axes.
And this is a result
that is very useful when
calculating moments of inertia.
Of course, we could
calculate the moment
about any axis we wanted.
And we'll see that in a moment.
For example, we know that
for a rod of length L
that the moment of inertia
through the center of mass
was 1/12.
And let's call the length of the
rod L. So we have a length L.
And let's assume it's
a uniform object.
And we'll calculate a moment
of inertia through an axis
through the end.
And so in this case, d
is equal to L over 2.
And so I about the
end axis is 1/12 mL
squared plus the mass
times L over 2 square
and a 12 plus a quarter
is 1/3 mL squared.
And that means that
all you need to know
is the moment through
the center of mass,
and you can calculate the
moment through any other axis.
Very useful theorem called
the parallel axis theorem.
Now as I said, we can
calculate the moment s.
And just to show you very
quickly, if we pick s here,
and we pick our little dm
there, and we have a distance x,
then the moment
about s-- and let's
say that dm is equal to
the total mass divided
by the length times some
little distance dx--
then the moment is dm times
x squared, where x we'll
give this an
integration variable
x prime goes from 0
to x prime equals l.
And so we have for our
dm m over L dx prime.
Remember, that's our
integration variable.
And we have x squared.
So that's x prime squared.
And this is just the
integral of x cubed over 3.
So we have 1/3 m over L x prime
cubed evaluated from 0 to L,
and that comes out
to 1/3 mL squared.
And that's in agreement with
the parallel axis theorem.
And that's an example of
parallel axis theorems.
You can do the same thing with
the disk or other objects.